a pandemic spiraling out of control a
historic military defeat and a border
crisis to boot americans are starting to
think things weren't as bad as they
thought under former president donald
trump
the mounting issues on all fronts have
led to the surprise conclusion that
trump is now seen as being as good a
president as biden suggesting the
honeymoon is being replaced with buyer's
remorse first on the list afghanistan
washington's shameful defeat that
concluded its 20-year long war was the
last straw for many americans the
disastrous withdrawal of u.s troops and
surrendering of millions of dollars of
military tech to the taliban had
republicans and democrats alike
demanding the biden administration be
held accountable
[Music]
afghanistan might feel like a world away
from america but there's no shortage of
problems at home under biden's
administration
earlier this month biden announced a
number of vaccine testing and mask
mandates which is proving to be the
latest american political spat connected
to the pandemic affecting around
two-thirds of the u.s workforce it
wasn't long before the cries that biden
is violating people's freedom of choice
were heard 24 republican state attorney
generals are even threatening lawsuits
really disrupts and divides the country
it increases the division in terms of
vaccination when we should all be
together
along the campaign trail biden promised
to make the country's southern border a
more humane place instead thousands of
migrants are living in horrific
conditions like under the del rio
international bridge the immigration
crisis is getting worse as thousands
more asylum seekers come knocking at the
us's door and to top it all off biden's
approach hasn't changed much from that
of the trump administrations kids are
still being put in cages and despite
biden's many promises to would-be green
card holders many migrants are being
deported back home without getting their
chance at asylum
[Music]
with a track record like bidens and not
even a whole year in office it's no
wonder over half of america thinks the
country is on the wrong track
you